hey guys I'm Abby start welcome to
Abby's kitchens the holidays can be
super hectic so you need a good balanced
breakfast help fuel you through each
busy day so I partnered with the Florida
Department of citrus who sponsored this
video to bring you three easy vegan
citrus filled brunch recipes that feel
really festive and indulgent because
after all it is the holidays but are
actually really well balanced and
nutritious I'm using Florida orange
juice because it's an excellent source
of vitamin C for collagen formation and
immunity perfect for cold and flu season
it's also a good source of potassium and
folate for heart health and contains no
added sugar so it's a naturally sweet
and refreshing addition to any holiday
recipe or spread so let's do this first
up my orange and Kuby salad I start by
making the dressing and that means
taking some seeds out of a vanilla bean
and popping it into some Florida orange
juice with a little bit of maple syrup
and giving it a good stir
next we build our salad and that means
putting down some sungold Kiwis green
Kiwis some Florida grapefruit segments
and some Florida orange segments now we
assemble I give it a generous coating
with some of that beautiful orange
dressing top it off with some
pomegranate arils and finish with some
pistachios enjoy
[Music]
next up my orange cream cheese pudding I
start by preparing the pudding to a bowl
I add some unsweetened almond milk
Florida orange juice chia seeds maple
syrup and the zest of one Florida orange
[Music]
give it a good stir to incorporate those
chia seeds and then pop it in the fridge
to refrigerate overnight the next
morning I add in some almond yogurt and
then give it a good stir to incorporate
that yogurt now it's time to layer your
pudding add a layer of your chia pudding
then add some Florida orange segments
Florida grapefruit segments pomegranate
arils and some sliced almonds talk with
another layer of your chia pudding and
add some more Florida citrus pomegranate
arils
and some almonds enjoy and finally my
orange cranberry pancakes I start by
preparing the batter by making a flax
egg by mixing together some unscreened
almond milk with some flax seed giving
it a good stir and refrigerating it
until it turns into a nice gloopy egg
like consistency then to a bowl I add
some whole wheat flour some cinnamon
some baking powder baking soda salt
melted coconut oil my flax egg and of
course some Florida orange juice give it
a good stir until it all comes together
then fold in some dried cranberries
now it's time to cook them add a little
bit of coconut oil to a nonstick skillet
then add in quarter cup servings of our
batter fry on each side until golden
brown and then talk with some Florida
citrus and maple syrup so guys I hope
you feel a little bit more prepared for
your holiday brunch with these three
healthy recipes using Florida orange
juice and thank you again to the florida
department of citrus for sponsoring this
video if you guys want some more great
recipes using citrus and some nutrition
information be sure to check out the
link in the video description I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with some your go to a holiday
brunch recipes subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen bye
[Music]